hello do you perhaps have some brain
cells to spare
please please i need
i need brain cells someone help me
don't know what i'm talking about i have
watched way too many
wiki wow videos and if you don't know
who she is i'm giving you one chance
right now
i'm quite serious in case you're still
here remember
danielle bregoli that's not my name you
pronounce it wrong catch me outside how
about that
basically where we first were we're a
bit
that's kind of funny oh no what is wrong
with humanity which
which dark corner and or pit did she
crawl out of well the new kid on the
block
is a sweet innocent girl whoa wiki
well there's one thing you need to know
about wiki wow
the main personal trait self-acclaimed
by her
is that she's black
now she's your typical savage instagram
teenager doing just crazy things
who knows what she's gonna do next
[Music]
this for poppy jj and malou
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] y'all
[Music]
[ __ ] tommy jj [ __ ] mellow
it's pretty good stuff here guys
somewhere along the line
wiki realized that she is not just your
ordinary citizen
she discovered finally a mission from
god
he split the heavens just for wiki wow
and said wiki i have special plans for
you
i am not done with you yet and here's
what she came up with
yes my birthday is march 7th
but july are you sure about that is it
really
that's they do i don't know if people
are sure about that 19th was that day i
found that i was black
like this whole my whole entire life my
mom kept telling me your white your
white
i never believed her because i knew i
was black but
july 19 i did some history
i went on ancestry.com and i found out
black and this whole time i knew it i
knew i was a black girl
so so i just consider that to be my
birthday because it's just a very
exciting holiday for me so i that's
right
she discovered but no one literally no
one else saw
you guys don't understand she is 25
she even posted her ancestry result
online
that's 44. she's 44 african guys
i'm having poppy jj's babies he's the
baby daddy
i just don't know if they hit because
he's a virgin
but like they gonna be real real cute
beautiful
chocolate babies running around we're
having twins by the way
and like but they gonna be beautiful
because we both black
this discovery truly changed wiki
world's life
making plans about her chocolate babies
but oh no no of course there's people
who always have to be hating i know i
know
it's frustrating getting criticism
online i don't like it either
okay i'm on i'm on wiki woah side all
the way
all the way she posted the ancestry
results guys
but of course haters makes me so angry
they're
racist haters i gotta tell y'all so
y'all keep trying to say i'm not black
i'm white yeah wiki i would never say
that i would absolutely
be on me why people would say something
like that just
cannot comprehend is racist as [ __ ] how
you
synthesis sit here and tell me what race
i
am if i say i'm black then i'm black i
see
c93.com yeah that's right
that's right and remember that one time
you probably forgot about this but
remember that one time i was in the
bridge in this video game
[Music]
i did it yeah my hair might be blonde
and straight
y'all never heard of a pearl or a
straightener
a strainer so you get it don't use the
meme review clap please wiki
all right i don't go there and steal
your ethnicity don't come here and steal
my memes please
and you go like this i'm black in the
story get that out of my face y'all
shouldn't make me mad
yeah don't make her mad guys please do
not make wiki will mad
oh no no still not convinced you say
stupid haters
always needs double evidence well
yes that phone is actually extremely
black
she makes a great point look at that
photo of mariah carey
she's extremely white as you can tell
she is
as you can tell by these solid evidence
that we could whoa
whoa wiki sorry i apologize whoa it's
literally right there
there's solid evidence that what wiki
has displayed to you right here
how can you just possibly dispute this
stop hating please stop hating on wild
wiki
i am black you see ancestry
is extremely solid evidence
just uh just one example for example
elon musk
from south africa as you can tell he is
also
extremely bananas he sent a card to
space that's insane
am i right guys thumbs up this video now
if you agree
this topic of ethnicity of course
interesting as it may be it's not what
defines what wiki
what defines her among other things
many things for that matter is her
incredibly
beautiful tear-breaking song song
singing talent is what i'm trying to say
jesus christ yeah i'm feeling good today
so i'mma sing for y'all you might want
to turn up your volume for this one
you'll make it look like it's magic
oh yeah cause i see nobody
nobody but you you
you you i never confused
[Applause]
that's really good that's really good
wow
it's like some weird gucci gang abortion
hybrid that's just somehow
mated
it's incredible i can almost tell what
language she sings in
it just breaks all boundaries that we
are normally used to
inspiring stuff if you think that's it
inspiring
we haven't even gotten started with her
inspirational quotes
she may have been blessed by god by this
epiphany
of who she is but she also blesses us
with her wisdom of course hey look
i just wanna tell y'all that first of
all i love you
and you can do anything you put your
mind to you
anything don't let people sit there and
doubt you and say you can't do it
and then you know what i'm saying it
might even be your friends that's saying
that bro but like
you just gotta do your own thing you
know what i'm saying stay blessed uh
stay
prayed up thank you you're gonna hate us
yes
you can't care what people think bro
like yeah i must say this camera angle
is great by the way i'm loving it and
when people say your face is lopsided
it's not true don't listen to the haters
second of all like like you think if i
care i'll still be i still
you think i'll be where i am today no
i wouldn't can we quote that last bit it
was just like true poetry
like you think if i care i'll still be i
still
well ricky is just so talented and so
incredible that sometimes when she
speaks
it's almost like she's talking through
another being
through a higher power and if you don't
understand
it's because you don't have that
intellect i'm finna kiss [ __ ]
honey with y'all i don't know about
y'all but i haven't got my ass beaten
folks yes
and ain't nothing wrong getting your ass
you know what i'm saying as long as
y'all you don't go
like a [ __ ] about it like yeah yeah she
beat my ass but look and then i was like
[ __ ] you be my ass
but you still a [ __ ] and that's just
honey like
you mean my ass ain't gonna stop me from
talking [ __ ] cuz [ __ ] i'm scared like
of course just because you be my ass
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] you feel me
like for those of you plebeian beings
that don't understand what will wiki is
saying here
sive is now going to translate part of
this video
so you can understand and follow the
great word along
i'm finna kee share the honey with y'all
i don't know about y'all but i haven't
asked me
folks yes
i don't even know oh hey i didn't see
you there
guess what i missed for halloween
yeah that's right some of y'all white
folks out here want to be racist and
[ __ ]
and paint your face is black for
halloween guess what
that's right that's right she's going as
a white girl for halloween
pushing boundaries on political topics
social issues
truly groundbreaking stuff my take on
culture
a portion um
i just wanna because i've been getting a
lot of comments talking about
culture appropriation but i just want to
give y'all my take on it coming from a
black girl
and
i don't know why i thought she might say
something else i don't
some people out here are saying that woe
wiki isn't gangsta
she's not thug uh excuse me then how
come she has the mark of the intellect
hmm gang [ __ ]
also a master swimmer
now of course as angry as this makes me
[Music]
ricegum
stupid rice i'm always criticizing these
instagram children
just had to go and hate on my girl whack
it wow
you keep my name out your mouth you use
little kids for the clout
you disappear bro is that all you can do
you [ __ ] how old are you and you're
just a little kid like bro you don't
even write your own songs
you're trying to do a better job because
your raps still suck
why am i even wasting my time right now
i'm not even wasting my time i'm gonna
make a dish on you
you just try my life that's right well
wiki did a diss track and it
absolutely killed it it absolutely
destroyed ricegum career
worse than idubbbz and here's the
aftermath
i have an announcement to make so if
anyone
took a fence onto my rice gum diss track
please don't take offense because it's
only two ricegum because he was being
racist towards me
yes and it's only towards him and like
actually just to let y'all know like
when i was younger i used to think i was
asian
oh my god
just take a dna test
but what wiki does best out of these all
things
is spread positivity hey negative ass
[ __ ]
why are your [ __ ] so negative stop
being so negative that's
right [ __ ] you i feel this positive
energy just
being blasted by thank you
god is blessing you you are blessed
[ __ ] maybe you wasn't so busy hating on
[ __ ]
being so goddamn negative all the time
yes living like this too i could see the
whole city of l.a [ __ ]
maybe of you if you wanted to what is
that like that's not a lady
what are you talking about stop hitting
stop
stop that [ __ ] now i love everybody
i love everybody i love you thank you
for leaving my [ __ ] time if you want
me so busy hey
you gonna get some money get that [ __ ]
out of your heart that [ __ ] ain't good
for you
that [ __ ] ain't good for you if you want
to hide
need a lot of people i want to see them
succeed
but you're too busy you can't even
exceed yourself if you want something
you can get the money soon go get some
money
[Music]
you